I came to talk about first principles
and communities that I love especially
East Palo Alto California which is full
of amazing people it's also a community
that's oddly separated by the 101
freeway that runs through Silicon Valley
on the west side of the freeway and Palo
Alto are the haves on just about any
dimension you think of education income
access to water on the east side of the
freeway or they have knots and even if
you don't know East Palo Alto you might
know this story of East Side disparity
whether it's the separation of the
railroad tracks and he's Pittsburgh or
the Grosse Pointe gate in East Detroit
or East st. Louis or East Oakland he's
Philly why is it the communities on the
social economic and environmental margin
they tend to be on the east sides of
places turns out it's the wind if you
look at the earth from the North Pole
you'd see that it rotates
counterclockwise the impact of this is
that the wind in the northern and the
southern hemispheres blow in the same
direction as the rotation of the earth
to the east it's a way to think about
this is imagine you're sitting around a
campfire you got to see ten people you
got to keep everyone warm the question
is who sits with the smoky wind blowing
in their face and the answer is people
with less power this campfire dynamic is
what's playing out in cities not just in
the US but all around the world
East London these side of Paris is this
way East Jerusalem even down the street
from where we're sitting right now that
marginalized community is East Vancouver
I'm not the only one to notice this I
nerd it on this hard for years and I
finally found a group of economic
historians in the UK who modeled
industrial era smokestack dispersion and
they came to the same conclusion
mathematically that I'd come to as an
anthropologist which is wind and
pollution or driving marginalized
communities to the east the dominant
logic of the industrial era is about
disparity it's about haves and have-nots
and that's become part of our culture
that's why you know exactly what I'm
talking about if I tell you someone's
from the wrong side of the tracks that
phrase comes from the direction that
wind would blow dirty train smoke to the
east usually I'm not saying every single
community in the East is on the margin
or every community on the margin is in
the East but I'm trying to make a bigger
point about disparity by design so if
you find yourself talking about any
cardinal direction or a freeway a river
some train tracks you're talking about
an East Side community now the wind is
obviously a natural phenomenon but the
Human Design decisions that we make to
separate ourselves is not natural
consider the fact that every East Side
community and the United States was
built during the era of legal
segregation we clearly weren't even
trying to design for the benefit of
everyone so we ended up dealing with
issues like redlining so this is where
the government literally created maps to
tell bankers where they shouldn't lend
these are some of those actual maps and
you'll notice how the red tends to be
clustered on the east sides of these
cities those financial design decisions
became a self-fulfilling prophecy so no
loans turned into low property tax base
and that bled into where schools and a
less well prepared workforce and lo and
behold lower incomes it means you can't
qualify for a loan just a vicious
downward spiral and that's just the case
with lending we've made similarly
sinister design decisions on any number
of issues from water infrastructure to
where we decided to place grocery stores
versus liquor stores or even for whom
and how we design and fund technology
products collectively this list of harms
is the artifact of our more primitive
selves I don't think this is how we'd
want to be remembered but this is
basically what we've been doing to East
Side Communities for the last century
the good news is it doesn't have to be
this way we got ourselves into this East
Side dilemma through bad design and so
we can get out of it with good
and I believe the first principle of
good designs actually really simple we
have to start with the commitment to
design for the benefit of everyone so
you remember the campfire metaphor if
you want to benefit everyone
maybe we just sit in a horseshoe so
nobody gets the smoke in their face now
I got to make a note to the gentrify
errs because the point of this image is
not to say you get the role in the East
Side communities and just move people
out of the way because you don't but the
point is if you start with this first
principle of benefiting everyone then
elegant solutions may become more
obvious than you assume what are the
elegant solutions to close this gap
between Palo Alto and East Palo Alto in
Silicon Valley I gotta like the odds of
starting with EPA it's in the middle of
Silicon Valley the epicenter of
innovation and wealth creation if we can
solve this problem anywhere it ought to
be here and if we can solve the problems
for EPA we could apply those solutions
to other Eastside communities if you
think about it it's actually a massive
investment opportunity and an
opportunity to drive policy change and
philanthropy but at the core it's this
fundamental design principle this choice
of whether we're going to decide to take
care of everyone and it's a choice we
can make loved once we've got the
capital we've got technology on our side
and it keeps getting better we've got
some of the best entrepreneurs in the
world in this building and in these
communities right now but the
fundamental question is what are we
designing for more haves and have-nots
more disparity or parity the choice to
come together because the reality is
this is not the industrial era we don't
live in the era of legal segregation so
the punchline is there is no wrong side
of the tracks and all I'm saying is we
should design our economy and our
communities with that in mind thank you
[Applause]